hi everyone welcome to dev 301
production grade build security for
developer workflows
my name is christopher sanson i'm a
product manager at google working on
developer tooling and with me is anthony
bouchong specialist customer engineer
who will be joining us a little bit
later to give a demo about some of the
new features and concepts we'll be
talking about
the increase in cyber and ransomware
attacks over the last year including
high profile cases such as solarwinds
has been a wake-up call for the industry
security is top of mind for companies
large and small across all verticals
in may the white house issued an
executive order on improving the
nation's cyber security in face of
increasingly sophisticated and
persistent threats to the public and
private sectors
in this 20-minute talk we're going to
introduce some specific actions that you
can take to create a more more secure
build environment on google cloud
over the last 20 years google has built
some of the most secure computing
systems in the world pioneering concepts
such as xero trust
as part of gcp we're bringing these
internal best practices to our cloud
customers through both open standards
and integration in a variety of ways
into gcp's managed services
in june of this year we launched open
source insights an exploratory
visualization site for viewing the
dependencies of open source projects and
in july we announced salsa slsa an open
framework based on internal google best
practices for formalizing the criteria
around software supply chain integrity
to help the industry and open source
ecosystem secure the software
development life cycle
ci cd is one of the most critical paths
for securing your software supply chain
it's the gatekeeper by which code
changes are released out to your users
and has many entry points for
vulnerabilities pulling resources from a
large number of internal and external
sources while accepting contributions
from hundreds or maybe even thousands of
developers and other contributors at
your company
in the solar winds breach that in part
led to the white house executive order
it was actually a compromise built
system
that attackers used to inject malware
into the candidate release that was
ultimately published downstream users
so in this talk we're going to focus in
on the build process specifically and
talk about how to improve the security
posture of your build environment and
we're going to do this by focusing on
three main areas one network security
two build permissions and three binary
authorization
so let's start with network security
uh one of the risks to an organization
is data exfiltration at build time built
by their nature typically handle a large
amount of private intellectual property
across source code databases and
artifact repositories
now actually we want to minimize the
risk of any of this data
egress to the public internet whether it
happens to be you know maliciously or
just simply accidentally
the most common way the companies do
this is by hosting resources inside
their private network behind a firewall
traditionally this is meant then that
you are self-hosting your own ci cd
solution
and besides just the additional overhead
and total cost of ownership around
developer velocity of having to install
manage upgrade and scale this system it
also means that you're responsible for
securing it
and as we saw with the solarwinds attack
bad actors can uh try to corrupt or
attack the build system itself
uh in the case of solar winds where um
at build time a on when a file was
fetched from the source repo it was
actually swapped out with malicious code
and then sent to downstream users
through the compile build and publish
process
so let's take a different approach fully
managed solutions like google's cloud
build offer a different tactic and are
hosted and managed by google cloud
running in google's secure network
taking the burden off of you and your
team for having to secure the system
itself in terms of accessing the
workers that builds run on
in june cloud build launched private
pools a new feature which lets you
securely connect a fully managed build
system into your private network using
vpc network peering
it supports private ips on the worker
data regionalization and static ip
ranges for iplo listing
another common pattern with this
firewall approach alone is that in many
organizations it's treated as sort of
all or nothing there's inside the
firewall and outside the firewall and
once inside you can access anything that
is also inside the private network
now one of the best practices that we
want to follow is that builds can access
only what they need to and nothing more
so let's say for example that you have
resources in multiple gcp projects that
your build needs to access
how can we configure cloud build so they
can access these resources but only
these resources and nothing else that
would be sort of a attack factor
so this is where vpc service controls
come in with private pool support for
vpc service controls you can configure
cloud build to restrict access more
granularly to just the services that it
needs to access
additionally you can use vpc service
controls on the project that the worker
pool itself is in
to restrict egress add an additional
layer of security against
leakage of data to the public internet
using private pool support for the gcp
org policy you can enforce that all
builds are run on these approved worker
pools that were successfully set up by
your security team
so now we talked about uh network
security let's move over to build
permissions where we have two main goals
again we want to grant builds only the
permissions they need and nothing more
and second we want to avoid the
escalation of permissions from the build
system to developers we don't want
developers to be able to access our
production environments directly or
decrypt production secrets that the
build system needs but developers
shouldn't really have direct access to
so as an example let's say we have two
environments staging and production
the first thing we're going to do is
enforce that all changes go through our
source repo or version control system
which then invokes the build
automatically this has a number of
benefits including
you know change history
you know audit trails ci tests and
using protective branches we can enforce
that only developers that have commit
rights commit rights to the prod branch
have the ability to invoke the
production release pipeline
this lets us use pull requests to add a
uh approval or manual review layer to
all suggested changes from sort of
developers that don't have permission to
release directly to production
likewise
we're going to want to make sure that
the staging build doesn't have
permissions to access our production
environment either which would allow
another escalation of permissions to uh
environments and secrets that should not
be accessible from our staging pipeline
for that we're going to take advantage
of a new feature of cloud build for user
provided service accounts
in this instance we're going to create
two service accounts one for our staging
bill and one for our production build
and grant them the respective
permissions that they need so they can
only access the resources that are
needed in each of those environments
next we're going to use cloud builds
integration with secret manager for
managing the secrets
with club builds native secret uh
manager integration
uh secrets are only decrypted at build
time and so not available in plain text
in the build config or to developers and
because you're using secret manager it's
much easier and faster to rotate secrets
frequently further improving your
security posture
the last thing we're to do is add a
manual approval step for the production
pipeline using cloud builds approval
features
we are going to make sure that an admin
or other approved reviewer is able to
manually review and approve all
production deployments
and all of this is in the spirit of
again preventing access from individual
developers to production environments
and other secrets that they should not
be able to access directly while
enabling the build system to
deploy to production
so now we've talked about build
permissions as well let's move on to the
last topic which is binary authorization
so we've created our build pipeline that
builds our container and deploys it out
in this particular case kubernetes
engine or cloud run
through our continuous delivery pipeline
whether that could be the newly
announced cloud deploy
an open source solution like spinnaker
or even cloud build itself
but how do we enforce that only approved
bills are deployed to our runtime
environments what's stopping a bad or
unauthorized actor from building their
own image and then deploying that out
directly or injecting it into our cd
pipeline
for this we're going to leverage binary
authorization from gcp which lets you
define deployment policies for which
containers can and can't be deployed
so in this case let's create a policy
that says only containers built by cloud
build can be deployed out to gke or
cloud run
this will ensure that any unsigned
images or images signed by an untrusted
build system will fail our policy check
and not get deployed out to our
production users whether
trying to be deployed directly or
through our cd pipeline
lastly cloud build will create and
assign an asset station for each image
that it builds
saying that it was built by cloud build
allowing it to pass the binary authors
and verification process and get
deployed out to our environment
so we talked quickly about uh cloud
build and how you can use cloud build to
improve your security posture to create
a more secure build environment while at
the same time improving developer
productivity and reducing operational
overhead all together
so we talked about some of the features
that were newly launched in 2021
including private pools user provided
service accounts secret manager
integration manual approvals and
better support for binary authorization
now let's hand it off to anthony for a
demo of some of what we discussed
anthony
thanks christopher
let's dive into how we can put these
principles into practice
let's start by taking a look at our
cloudrun application in this case we're
utilizing a containerized python flask
web app that's accessible at this url
and it's only accessible by authorized
users so we'll provide a token when
issuing a request
and you'll see that we get a html page
in response to our request
our cloudrun application actually has
binary authorization enabled as a
reminder binary authorization is the
ability to only admit a certain set of
container images
to your runtime environment like
cloudrun or gke
in this case we've configured binary
authorization to only approve
images that have been signed by the
cloud run a tester in this case the
cloud runner tester is only signing
images that have been built with google
cloud build
we can see binary authorization in
action if we try to deploy an image to
the cloud run service that was not
signed by our tester
so in this case for our next 2021 app
you'll see here that i have a container
image that's tagged rogue and this was
built out of band not utilizing google
cloud build
and if i was trying to deploy this
container image to cloud run
we should actually see our binary
authorization policy in action by
denying that container image to be
deployed to cloud run
now that we've demonstrated how we can
handle images that we don't trust let's
take a look at the automation that cloud
build provides and how we can build
images that we do trust
to build our container image what we're
actually utilizing are google cloud
builds support for triggers
both of these triggers are connected to
my github repository titled next 2021
which actually has our application code
the first trigger
kicks off builds automatically based on
any changes to a feature branch
in this case it'll run builds that build
a container image signs a container
image and will actually open up a pull
request against the main branch in the
github repository
the second trigger actually kicks off
and deploys the container image to cloud
run based on any changes made to the
main branch
one of the things we want to consider
here is the ability to apply the
principle of least privilege and in this
case we're actually able to do this by
separating the service accounts that
each of these triggers utilize you can
see here for the first trigger we're
utilizing a service account that is
titled build next 2021 and this has
permissions to the container registry
and things like that that actually help
it to perform uh the build that it needs
to run and then the second service
account is called deploy next 2021 which
has permissions to deploy to cloud run
while in this example i'm utilizing a
github.com repository it is important to
call out that google cloud build also
has support for self-hosted source code
management systems like github
enterprise so you can actually see here
that in cloud build i actually have a
host connection to a private github
enterprise server that i
also utilize in google cloud and you can
see that i've actually made connections
to various repositories in that github
enterprise instance
this means that i can also create cloud
build triggers on these private
self-hosted repositories
now let's take a look at the actual
build that our first trigger is running
this trigger is looking in the build
folder and the first trigger
specifically is looking at the
build.yaml
specification for google cloud build
our first build step is building our
container image that will end up running
in cloud run and we're actually
publishing that to google container
registry
and you can see here that we're
utilizing cloud native build packs to
automatically generate that container
image
once we've signed the container image
our final build step actually will open
up a pull request against our github
repository and you can see here that the
way that we're able to do this
is that we're utilizing the github api
and in order to authorize ourselves or
the build to be able to perform this
action we're providing a
github token
and so one of the critical components of
a secure build environment is
careful secret management
in this case google cloud build allows
us to natively access
secrets stored in google cloud secret
manager so you can see in this scenario
we're actually storing our token our
github token in secret manager and
providing that back to the build itself
as an environment variable this means
that we are not providing static
credentials
to our actual build or codifying that
into our build container images but
rather these are dynamically accessed
utilizing the service account
which is provided to the build
if we jump over to google cloud secret
manager we'll see our secret or github
token and we'll see here under
permissions that we've actually granted
secret accessor permissions to our build
next 2021 service account which is being
utilized by google cloud build and the
important thing to note is that this is
a granular permission it is not for all
secrets that are stored in secret
manager but rather on a per secret
access basis
the next important field to call our
attention to in the
cloud build specification is under
options worker pool
this actually allows for us to specify
on a per build basis
whether or not a build should run in a
cloud-build private pool
so what is a cloud-build private pool
well private pools extend the user
configurability for the workers that
actually run a user's build
so in this case we can specify
additional things like regions
we can also specify and have access to
more machine types and perhaps most
importantly we have private vpc
connectivity to access private resources
either within our own network in google
cloud or within a data center that is
connected to our
google cloud vpc
so you can see here that i've specified
for sandbox private pool to have
connectivity to sandbox vpc private
pools which is actually running the
github enterprise server that i was
showing earlier in this demonstration
not only do we get private vpc
connectivity with cloudville private
pools we actually have the ability to
remove external ips from our workers
altogether and in general can now
consider how we can use vpc service
controls to secure our build perimeter
running in private pools
so now let's actually trigger this first
build that'll run on a private pool
so i'm going to change the web
application and just add a couple of
small very minor changes by adding a
couple exclamation points
in some of the html
and i'm going to commit this to
development marriage and then what we're
going to want to do is create a feature
branch that will kick off our trigger
now that we're done with the development
branch
and as you can see our build is now
queued to run in usos 1 on a private
pool and if we actually dig into the
build we can see our build steps which
builds a container image a test the
container image or signs the container
image and then creates that github pull
request
and after a short amount of time we can
see that our build has completed the
final step being the pull request being
created so if we actually jump over to
the repository we can actually see the
pr from feature against main
and so we can review that
we can see that our build is completed
and now we can utilize git as an
opportunity to basically gate the next
build because we have the opportunity to
either approve and merge these changes
or we can close the pr
so in this case once we click on merge
we're actually going to kick off the
second trigger which will deploy the
service to cloud run
so we're going to click that
and that branch has now been
successfully merged
so if we quickly glance at the build
that is going to run
we can see here that it's a single step
and we're just using gcloud as our build
step and we are passing in the arguments
to basically deploy to cloud run
our latest image that we built
now let's take a look at our last build
from the second trigger that will deploy
our new container image
to google cloud run
one of the things to consider
is that many teams will often introduce
a manual approval stage for pipelines
that deploy to a production environment
and this basically allows for an
operator or developer to have that
final decision to actually promote
an image into a production environment
so as you can see google cloud build has
actually introduced the notion of manual
approvals
so we can see that the trigger has
created our build however the build has
not begun to execute to actually deploy
to cloudrun because we have not yet
approved it
so once we click off approve we may have
the ability to provide context on
perhaps monitoring or
certain documentation or a ticket
that actually captures
whatever metrics or heuristics that
allow us to promote this production
and we can click approve and our build
will actually begin to kick off and run
and after a short period of time we'll
see that our single step build has
completed and we have now deployed the
new container image to cloud run so
let's take a look at cloud run and we
can actually see that we have a new
revision this was the failed revision
that was not signed by the tester in
google cloud build so it failed to
deploy due to binary authorization but
because we built this image with cloud
build and it was actually properly
signed by the cloud run a tester that we
had it is now successfully deployed
and once we issued that request again to
our application
we can see our changes with the
additional exclamation points we
demonstrated how we can secure our build
environments with granular build
permissions a secure network perimeter
manual approvals and admission control
to targets like cloud run and gke back
to you christopher
thanks anthony
that was a great demo
now of course
what we just covered today was really
meant as an infrastruc as an
introduction and a high level overview
of some of the specific actions you can
take to secure
part of your larger end-to-end ecosystem
uh if you're interested in learning more
here are some additional talks uh here
at next around securing your software
supply chain that we highly recommend
you check out as well
thank you for your time and we're happy
to take any questions
you